[Música]
Boa noite, minhas amigas, meus amigos.
Boa noite, Ivan, que já deu seu boa
noite também. A medida que vocês forem
entrando, por favor, coloque a sua
mensagem de
saudação. Eu me senti muito sozinho na
live passada, quase ninguém interagiu
comigo. Na verdade, ninguém interagiu
comigo. Alguém disse dentro do WhatsApp
lá do grupo que estava acompanhando a
live, mas não se manifestou. Então,
dessa vez eu gostaria que todos vocês
que estiver assistindo, por favor, dê o
alô, porque eu me senti esquisito
fazendo uma live aparentemente para
ninguém. Boa noite, Alice Vog, um beijo
para você. Quem mais tá ao vivo,
pessoal? Vamosão se manifestando aí, por
favor. À medida que vocês vão entrando,
vão se manifestando. Bem, temos 22
perguntas hoje. Boa noite, Thago.
Obrigado por ter dado boa noite. Boa
noite a todos que estão assistindo.
Estou em caminho de festa. Opa, festa
boa, hein,
Alice? Que festa é essa aí que você vai
aniversário de
alguém? Bem, vamos lá. Temos várias
perguntas aqui para
responder. Primeiro, deixa eu colocar
aqui as perguntas na tela. Deixa eu ver
se tá bom. Tá bom, sim. Tá
legal. Maria Helena também está
presente. Ah, que mais?
Fando Casteliano também, obrigado por
est acompanhando a live. Antônio
Renato, vocês assistiram a live da
semana passada, pessoal? Porque eu
fiquei com a sensação que eu respondi
tanta pergunta na live passada e não
tive interação de vocês. Vocês
assistiram a live passada, mesmo que não
tenha sido ao vivo? Responda aí para
mim, por favor, se você assistir o vídeo
da live passada que tá lá no
YouTube. Então, nós temos essas
perguntas hoje. Primeira pergunta do
Antônio
Renato. Se uma pessoa plantar milho
transgênico, que nascer será transgênico
também ou ele vai perdendo a mutação até
se tornar natural? Em que local você
recomenda milho e feijão e trigo sem
mutação, de forma confiável para
plantar? Eu acho que o Antônio Renato tá
achando que eu sou
agrônomo. O Fernando Castelini falou que
a live passada ali assistiu sim, depois
assisti de novo. Obrigado por ter
assistido, tá pessoal? Foi de valia para
vocês. Se tiver alguma coisa nas lives
aí que não for de agrado, por favor,
vocês me comunicam, tá? A intenção é
melhorar sempre. Beleza?
Ã, bom, vamos lá. Vamos perguntar, vamos
responder a pergunta de agronomia,
porque agora o Antônio Renato seis
smouca, eu sou
agrônomo. Ai, ai, ai. Vamos
lá. Bem, eh pelo que eu pesquisei,
certo? A plantação de milho transgênico
vai gerar sementes que vão manter sim as
características genéticas modificadas,
porque o DNA alterado ele vai ser dado
pelas novas plantas. Isso ocorre porque
os transgênites são incorporados ao
genoma do milho e são transmitidos à
gerações seguintes sem perda natural de
mutação ao longo do tempo, né? Existe
sim a contaminação cruzada entre
plantações transgênicas e variedades
naturais.
OK? Então pode acontecer uma mistura
genética. Então para encontrar sementes
de milho,
feijão e trigo sem modificação genética
de forma confiável, é recomendado que
você vá atrás de sementes crioulas ou
orgânicas certificadas, como é o caso
das produzidas por rede de agricultura
familiar e agroecologia. Então a
Embrapa, como eu falei na semana
passada, ela tem variedades não
transgênicas. Tá? Como a
Brsembé, eu vou escrever isso aqui no
chat. Eh,
BRSBÉ, tá? Tô colocando a mensagem
aqui. Eh, então também você pode
conseguir essas sementes em feiras de
trocas de sementes e acetamentos rurais
ou comunidades tradicionais, onde há
preservação de variedades
locais e também certificadoras
independentes que garantem a ausência de
transgênicos mediante testes. Então, os
produtores têm que exigir o laudo de
análise molecular. Então, essa questão
do transênico vai continuar transgênico,
sim. Eh, de se esperar que ao longo aí
de muitas gerações de plantas vai ter
uma troca com as
variedades selvagens e vai ao pouquinho,
aos pouquinhos, perdendo a
característica transgênica, mas isso vai
demorar muito tempo, então não dá para
confiar que o transênico vai se tornar
natural dentro de um tempo, seja
razoável, tá?
Então não confie nesse nessa história,
não sei se você viu em algum lugar que o
transgênico vai virar a selvagem com o
tempo. Próxima pergunta. Existe local
específico para comprar confiabilidade
as galinhas em brapa 0,51 Carijó sem
risco de elas serem manipuladas
geneticamente? Então você tem que
recorrer às fontes oficialmente
reconhecidas, tá? A Embrapa 051, que é
desenvolvida pela Empresa Brasileira de
Pesquisa Agropecuária, ela é distribuída
por criatórios credenciados. É o caso da
Gramado Avicultura do Rio Grande do Sul.
Gramado Avicultura no Rio Grande do Sul,
que
oferece essas galinhas com garantia de
procedência e padrões sanitários
adequados, tá? Então você pode contactar
diretamente a Embrapa, Suínos e AVES e
ah perguntar para eles ou pode também
acessar o site para obter a lista
atualizada desses parceiros
autorizados, OK? Eles vão te dar
informações de várias regiões do Brasil.
Em relação às
carijós, é uma linhagem natural não
hibridizada. Ela é encontrada em
criatórios especializados em aves
caipiras ou por meio de associações de
agricultura familiar. Então, aves dessa
variedade podem ser adquiridas em feiras
agropecuárias, cooperativas rurais ou
através de órgãos como a Emater que
orientam produtores sobre fornecedores
idôneos, tá? Então a Embrapa
051, ela é uma seleção genética
convencional, ela não tem manipulação
transgênica. O cruzamento de raças Road
Island Red e Plot Rock. E as carijosas
são raças tradicionais preservadas por
criadores que valorizam características
naturais, sem intervenções artificiais,
além do melhoramento
zootécnico básico. OK.
Próxima
pergunta. Olha, se você não pegou alguma
coisa, você pode voltar depois o vídeo
que vai ficar
gravado. Existe câncer que se alimenta
de glicose e gordura. Isso já foi
falado. Sim. Eh, mas a ingestão de altos
índices de carboidratos pode facilitar o
surgimento de cânceres? Com
certeza. Tanto os que se alimentam de
glicose como que se alimentam de
gordura. Sim, isso é fato, tá? que eu
quis dizer não é que é para você se
entupir de carboidrato só porque existe
alguns cânceros que se alimenta de
derivado de gordura,
ok? Então com certeza isso não invalida
você ter uma dieta saudável e não comer
carboidrato em excesso ou carboidrato
refinado,
carboidrato de índice glicêmico alto ou
que
seja eh transformado muito rápido em
glicose, certo?
Então, não faça uso exagerado
carboidrato refinado ou carboidrato
simples, porque isso sim vai facilitar a
formação do câncer, tá?
Para mim é fato consumado que alimentos
com alto índice glicêmico vão elevar
rapidamente os níveis de glicose no
sangue. Isso vai estimular a liberação
de insulina e também vai estimular o
fator de crescimento semelhante à
insulina ao GF1. Esse GF1 ele é derivado
do hormônio
crescimento. Então as substâncias podem
funcionar como fertilizantes, entre
aspas, para células cancerosas,
promovendo a multiplicação, inibindo
mecanismos naturais de morte celular
programada. Então não deixe de fazer a
dieta
adequada. Então, só complementando, como
eu já falei em vários vídeos anteriores,
tá? a resistência ulínica, o excesso de
gordura visceral, de gordura altamente
inflamatória, vai criar um ambiente
propício através de liberação de
adposcinas e citocinas, propício para a
formação de
câncer, estimula angiogênese, que é a
formação de vasos pros
tumores. Existe também um fato
interessante que eu não sabia que
células cancerosas podem reciclar, entre
aspas, moléculas de gordura para
construir membranas celulares e
sinalizadores protumorais. Então a
gordura visceral também tem esse efeito
negativo. Vamos pra próxima pergunta. O
que é neurocisticercose?
Quais os perigos e como
evitar? Bem, trata-se de uma infecção
grave do sistema nervosocentral do
cérebro, principalmente causada pela
forma larval do parasita tênia. A tênia,
ela tem duas formas, a
larval, né, e a forma adulta, né? A
tênia comum, que é a solitária, ela fica
no intestino grosso, certo? Você pode
adquirir eh tênia quando você
come
uma um alimento, um vegetal que tem os
ovos do parasita, tá? Então você vai ser
vai ter a tênia, tá? Já a neurocistose
geralmente acontece quando você ingere a
carne que tem dentro dela, tá? O
parasita. Então existe essa diferença
aí, tá?
Então, o que acontece é quando você
ingere as larvas que estão dentro da
carne contaminada, elas podem migrar pro
cérebro, pra medula espinhal e outros
tecidos, formando cistos que
desencadeiam inflamação, crise
convulsível e outros problemas
neurológicos. Meu pai mesmo tem
neurocercose, até hoje ele tem que ficar
tomando anticonvulsivante, que ele toma
durante décadas para não ter crise
convulsiva. Então esse é o principal
problema aí da neurocissecose, da
epilepsia crônica que meu pai tem, que
tá presente até 80% dos casos
sintomáticos.
Pode dar também hidrocefalia, que é
acúmulo de líquido no cérebro, pode dar
dores de cabeça
incapacitantes. Em casos graves, risco
de morte por edema cerebral, que é
inchaço cerebral ou complicações
cirúrgicas. Então, a questão da
neuropsicecose é comum em regiões com
saneamento básico precário, era mais
comum no passado, né? como foi o caso do
meu pai, que cresceu nos anos 40 e 50,
que ele é de
1940, especialmente onde há criação de
porcos em condições inadequadas.
OK? Então, para quebrar a neurocisercose
é muito importante quebrar o ciclo de
transmissão, que é lavar as mãos com
água e sabão após usar o banheiro, antes
de manipular alimentos após contato com
suínos. Vegetais e frutas devem ser
lavados com água filtrada e higienizados
com solução
clorada. Consumir apenas água filtrada,
fervida ou
engarrafada. Cozinhar bem a carne de
porco. Eu acho que eu eh o caso do meu
pai foi que ele não cozinhou bem a carne
de porco e comeu uma carne que tinha
cisticerco. Porque quando você come ovo
que tá no vegetal contaminado,
geralmente você tem a tênia, não tem a
neursecose, ok?
tratamento adequado de pessoas que
tenham tenias. Então, pessoas infectadas
com a fama adulta da tênia, né, que é a
forma mais comum no intestino, tem que
ser tratados adequadamente com remédios
como prazicantel e niclosamida para
evitar a disseminação de ovos no
ambiente.
OK? E como é que se trata
neuropsicercose, né? através dos
antiparasitários que eu já
comentei, temos aí bendazol, prazicantel
e a
nicolosamida. Alguns casos você usa
corticordides como a dexametazona para
diminuir a inflamação
cerebral. Dentro da mência integrativa
existe uso de dieta
antiinflamatória que vocês conhecem bem.
Você pode utilizar suplementos como
zinc, ômega-3, vitamina
D, uso de probióticos para melhorar
saúde
intestinal e fitoterapia com ervas como
extrato de semente de
toranja, tem um efeito antiparasitário.
OK, vamos continuar.
Estudante, jovem de 28 anos, ri sozinho,
mas tem total controle de suas ações. E
quando está em público, se contém. E
quando está sentado no computador
balança as mãos involuntariamente.
Quando está na rua, fica sorrindo
sozinho, pois fica imaginando coisas,
situações engraçadas, tem dificuldade de
aprendizado e socialização. Você acha
que pode ser autismo? Olha, a descrição
que você tá fazendo, viu, estudante, que
você não quis se identificar, é muito,
muito parecida com meu filho, autista.
Ele tem 15 anos e muitas vezes eu pego
ele sorrindo, horrindo
sozinho, eh, muitas vezes balançando as
mãos, né? Ele tem vários assimos
motores, né? Ele balança bem bastante as
mãos, aí dá pulinhos,
tá? Eh, isso é bem comum no autismo, tá?
É lógico que eu não vou
conseguir diagnosticar assim só com
essas cinco linhas aí, nem é meu papel
aqui de fazer diagnóstico, mas eu acho
que é mais provável ser autismo, sim,
não parece ser TTH, nem esquizofrenia.
Esquizofrenia poderia até ser porque tem
alucinações,
tá?
Eh, mas não é essa geralmente a
manifestação da esquizofrenias.
esquizofrenia, geralmente as alucinações
são desagradáveis, tanto visuais quanto
auditivas, quanto fatórias, tá? Então,
me parece mais que seja um autismo isso
daí. Então, só lembrando, quais são as
características principais do autismo,
que é um diagnóstico muito abrangente,
né? é dificuldade na interação social,
comportamentos repetitivos, que são
estereotipias, que eu acabei de falar,
que é balançar as mãos, dar pulinhos,
né? Interesses restritos, que o meu
filho tinha muito isso quando era
criança, ele só comia determinados tipos
de alimentos, tinha problema com
texturas.
No caso dele não teve um
atraso, quer dizer, persistente. Ele
teve um atraso inicial de
desenvolvimento neuropsicomotor. Agora,
graças a Deus, ele tá dentro de um nível
adequado paraa idade dele, acompanhando
muito bem a escola, tirando boas notas,
tá? Mas sim, é muito comum dependendo do
grau do autismo, né? O grau de cuidados,
que grau um, grau dois, grau três. Meu
filho é grau um, mas se tiver grau dois
ou grau três, você vai ter atraso maior
desenvolvimento de habilidades
acadêmicas adaptativas.
Então, os adultos autistas geralmente
têm uma capacidade se conter em público,
né, que é um esforço consciente de
camuflagem
social. Eles aprendem a mascarar os
traços para adequar ambientes
neurotípicos.
Falando um pouquinho mais sobre
esquizofrenia, os sintomas mais comuns é
delírio, alucinação, que geralmente são
desagradáveis, não são coisas
engraçadas, e fala desorganizada. OK?
E também tem uma desconexão com a
realidade, que é uma coisa que você não
descreveu aqui num
comportamento. Mas certamente e esse
rapaz tinha ser avaliado aí por um bom
psiquiatra em conjunto com
psicólogo
e também talvez um
fonondiólogo. Tem que ser submetido a
testes, como é o caso da escala de
observação para diagnóstico do autismo,
que é escala A2, tá?
Bem, vamos continuar aqui em um vídeo
mais ou menos 5 anos atrás. Ah, essa
pergunta nesse formato é do Eliseu, né?
Ele não quis colocar o nome dele aqui,
mas é o Eliseu.
Certo. Em um vídeo mais ou menos 5 anos
atrás, você falou que a vitamina B,
ministrada por anos tinha o poder de
curar a esquizofrenia.
Não, eu falei que doses altas de
vitamina B de bola 3, segundo os
estudos, tá, do
psiquiatra
canadense, eh, que me fugiu o nome
agora, mas daqui a pouco eu vou
lembrar,
ele percebeu que vários casos de
esquizofreniam poderiam ser curados, não
são todos. Esse vídeo ainda está
atualizado parcialmente, tá? Novas
informações, tratamento já surgiram de
lá para cá dentro da
medicina funcional. Sim.
Tá. A medicina integrativa pode curar ou
só existe remissão? Não, não é cura, é
remissão, tá?
Não é cura,
remissão. A gente tem que entender que a
esofrenia ela é bem complexa e tem
vários fatores
aí em
conjunto. Eu também um momento eu falei
num vídeo que não era para associar com
antipsicóticos, né? O que
o o psiquiatra canadense na época
criticava muito é que se usava doses
altas de antipsicóticos e muitas vezes
quando ele utilizava a vitamina B3 em
doses mais altas ele conseguia livrar os
pacientes aos pouquinhos das doses altas
antipsicóticos.
Tem estudos recentes que mostram que
processos neuroinflamatórios, não só a
deficiência de
B3, estariam associados à esquizofrenia.
Existe estudos com medicamento chamado
minociclina, que é um antibiótico com
efeito
neuroprotetor, mas que ainda não estão
concluídos, que poderiam ajudar a
modular a
inflamação. E houve descobertas que
revelaram que alterações em
biomarcadores como nível de homocisteína
e B12 podem indicar risco de psicose e
ajudar a diferenciar esquizofrenia de
condições como TDAH e
depressão. Deixa eu ver se eu respondi
todas as perguntas.
Se uma pessoa com esquizofrenia leve,
não diagnosticada for ao seu
consultório, essa pessoa mesmo sem
diagnóstico, com exames de sangue
solicitados por você, dá para ter uma
ideia de que o cérebro daquela pessoa
está com
esquizofrenia? Eh, não, não é por causa
do exame de sangue. O diagnóstico não é
pelo exame de sangue, é
pela parte
comportamental, tá? Ah, os exames de
sexo são complementares aqui não são
para
diagnóstico, porque tem gente que tem
deficiência, por exemplo, de B12, ácido
fólico, nunca vai ter esquizofrenia,
pode ter fadiga crônica e pode ter
depressão, tá?
Bem, eu acho que eu já respondi essa
pergunta
aqui. Vamos para
próximo. Antônio Renato, tem uma
sugestão para você. Vi certa vez que
você fez uma live com estudioso político
sobre nova ordem mundial. Eu fiz duas,
na verdade. Eu fiz com o professor Luís
Antônio Peixoto do Vale e fiz com o
professor, caramba, esqueci o nome do
outro. Eh, vamos lá, vou continuar a
pergunta
aqui sobre Nova Ola Mundial. Tem um
aluno do Olavo de Cavalo chamado
Alexandre Costa. Ele tem livro sobre o
assunto e vejo que quando ele não sabe
de algo, ele simplesmente fala que não
sabe, é honesto, porque você não chama
ele para fazer uma live sobre o impacto
da nova ordem mundial e a indústria
farmacêutica. Pode ser. Eh, Alexandre
Costa, OK. Acho que não custaria nada
para você, já que você tem mais de
800.000 inscritos e uma
live e feita na casa de
casa. Um não acusta.
Eh, escreveu meio esquisito aqui, mas
acho que eu tô entendendo que ser feita
de casa a
live apenas tempo. Por que você não faz
uma live com ele e destrincha esse
assunto para nós, seus ouvintes? Veja a
live que ele fez no Caravelas Podcast.
Tá bom. Você tem o contato desse
Alexandre Costa aí, o Instagram dele
para eu falar com ele?
Antônio, existe cura para câncer na
medicina
integrativa? Na live passada você falou
que antes de fazer dieta cetogênica é
bom fazer exames de genoma. Quais
seriam? É fazer o exame nutro genético,
tá? Exame
nutrigenético. Quantos tipos de câncer
existem? Não sei. De cabeça não
sei. O câncer de pênis é gerado só pela
mais higiene mesmo? É o principal fator,
tá? Tendo higiene correta, é possível
evitar praticamente 100% do câncer de
pênis. que eu saiba, eu nunca vi nenhum
caso de canes que não houvesse problema
de
higiene. Tá? Então, repetindo, são
testes nutrigenéticos,
tá? Que esse é o nome que você tem que
procurar. Com o tempo, os exames de
exoma vão ficar mais viáveis e mais
baratos, tá? Hoje são caros porque vê
toda a carga genética da pessoa é bem
complicada hoje em termos de de custo,
tá? Então, o sequenciamento total de
genoma ainda não é uma realidade de
fácil acesso.
Aí, então eu te falei em relação ao
número de cânceres, tem mais de 200
variações, não tem um número exato,
tá? Os mais comuns é o de pele,
próstata, mama e pulmão e também deixino
grosso, tá? Então, primeiro é de pele,
segundo fica com fica competindo
próstata e testino grosso. E o pulmão
seria o quarto colocado.
Tô vendo agora aqui que existe um relato
de que a limpeza adequada, no caso da
pergunta do câncer de
pênis e a cirurgia, né, de posttectomia
ou circuncisão, poderiam reduzir em até
80% risco. Ele não tá dizendo que
elimina o risco, apesar que eu nunca
tenha visto câncer de pênis sem
problemas de higiene ou sem problemas aí
de fimose não corrigida, tá? Porque
geralmente a pessoa até tem gene boa,
pode até ter gên boa, mas teve uma
fimose muito acentuada que não foi
corrigido e a sujeira lá acumulada levou
a formação do
câncer. Tem um papel aí do HPV também,
então múltiplos parceiros sexuais
podem causar aí um risco maior de câncer
de pênis, tá?
Na sua opinião, por que os globalistas
querem proibir o cigarro e liberar
maconha? O professor Olavo criticava e
defendia o
cigarro e parece que ele tinha razão, já
que Doso antigamente fumava durante
décadas e parece que a maconha destrói a
pessoa em algumas
décadas, mas nunca conheci nenhum
maconheiro. Graças a Deus, na sua visão,
a maconha ela deve ser proibida mesmo a
curto
prazo. ela é muito mais
nociva, apesar de não ser divulgada para
o público no geral. Bem, a questão aí é
muito complexa, tá? Eu passo muito
remédio de extrato de
cannabis. O que eu penso sobre a essa
questão aí do da maconha é
que se liberar maconha existe uma chance
muito alta de aumentar o consumo de
outras drogas mais pesadas, tá? E muita
gente acontece esse argumento, fala que
é mentira, que isso não é bem assim,
mas o Brasil é um país que tem
instituições pouco confiáveis. E se você
liberar a maconha aqui no Brasil, eu
acho que a chance de aumentar o consumo
de outras drogas pesadas vai ser muito,
muito
alto. Então eu entendo hoje que na
prática no Brasil é como se a maconha já
tivesse sido liberada, porque o consumo
é tão extensivo e praticamente não tem
repressão para quem é usuário, não tô
dizendo para pros traficantes que
carregam aí toneladas, né, que muitas
vezes não são pegos, mas que pelo menos
se são pegos são presos, né? Agora, o
usuário hoje em dia, na prática, no
Brasil não é preço. Eu pelo menos não tô
vendo mais isso aqui na
minha rua tem um monte de gente
usuária. Eh, e realmente na minha, no
meu entendimento, o consumo de maconha
hoje é liberado na prática, apesar de
não ser. Eu acho que poderia ter um
efeito muito positivo de liberar o
consumo de maconha de acabar com parte
do tráfico de drogas, mas não ia acabar
porque tem outras drogas, né?
é um assunto extremamente complexo. Eu
não tenho nenhuma intenção aqui de ter a
última palavra sobre esse
assunto. Eu acho que os dois lados aí da
discussão tem os seus argumentos. Eu
acho que o uso de extrato de cannabis é
um remédio muito bom se for utilizado
somente em adultos em caso de criança.
Muito
muito parimonioso, porque existe
evidências de que mesmo um remédio no
extrato de cannabis, né, ou canabis deol
e derivados em
crianças, ele atrapalha o
desenvolvimento do cérebro. Então isso
tem evidência falando disso. Em adulto
não acontece isso, mas eu sei que tem
crianças epilépticas que já foram
muito beneficiadas com o uso de cannabis
na forma de extrato. Então é um assunto
muito, muito complicado, tá? Eh, a
questão que você tá colocando aqui, bem,
muita gente acredita que a queima do
papel e do tabaco é muito mais
complicada em si do que necessariamente
as substâncias que que tem ali no
tabaco, tá? Porque na hora que você
queima, libera um monte de toxinas que
parte vem do papel e parte vem do
tabaco. E que isso não acontece quando
você ingere, por exemplo, o extrato de
cannabis de outra maneira que não seja
ah com aumento de temperatura, né, com
com
queima. Ah, o cigarro, sim, é muito
prejudicial, tá?
Eh, até onde eu sei, não existe eh
claramente aí evidências de que o fumo
de
maconha equivalente ao cigarro seja tão
pior assim do ponto de
vista de câncer, por exemplo, tá? Lógico
que existe mais
substâncias eh psicoativas na maconha do
que no cigarro e que isso em exagero com
certeza causaria problemas maiores, tá?
Mas é muito difícil você achar alguém
que fuma maconha igual com a mesma
frequência que fuma o cigarro, tá? Então
os dois são ruins no final do dia,
tá bem? Eu não sei se se eu respondi a
sua pergunta de uma maneira muito
clara. Deixa eu ver se tem mais algumas
informações que eu posso acrescentar na
sua resposta.
Bem, segundo a Organização Mundial de
Saúde, o cigarro tabagismo é responsável
por 8 milhões de óbitos por ano. 8
milhões de pessoas morrem por ano,
incluindo 1,2 milhão de não fumantes
expostos ao fumo passivo, tá?
Então tem umas correlações bem robustas
entre o consumo de cigarro, doenças
cardiovasculares, câncer de pulmão,
DPOC, enfizema, câncer de
bexiga, tá? Isso por conta de danos ao
DNA pelos hidrocarbonetos aromáticos
policílicos, tá? Que acontecem aí quando
você queima o tabaco e o papel.
Essa afirmação de que os idosos fumantes
de décadas passadas tinham menos
Alzheimer, eu acredito que não seja
porque eles por causa do fumo
especificamente, mas sim por conta do do
da do aumento da toxicidade ambiental e
dos outros fatores de risco nós temos
estamos tendo hoje em dia, tá?
principalmente alimentação e também
agora a proteína
spike. Deixa eu ver se tá faltando falar
alguma coisa mais
aqui. Pelo que você falou, o Olavo de
Carvalho, ele defende o cigarro comum, é
isso?
Olavo criticava e defendia o
cigarro. Criticava maconha e defendia o
cigarro. Eu não conheço muito bem a a as
ideias do Olaf de Cavalo sobre cigarro,
não, tá?
Bem, eu não sei se ele tem esse
argumento de que existe uma falta de
relação entre cigarro e câncer em geral,
mas isso não é verdade, tá? Se foi esse
o argumento do L Carvalho, não sei se
foi esse, não é o caso, tá?
Tem estudos muito sólidos mostrando que
o tabaco tem relação com câncer.
Sim. E até onde eu sei, o próprio Lav de
Cavalo teve tumor de traqueia, né? Então
que porque ele fumava,
né? Bem, Antônio, você tá na live? Se
você tiver, me fala se eu respondi a tua
pergunta de maneira do jeito que você
queria. Vamos paraa
próxima. Quando uma pessoa com
transtorno mental como o autismo, quem
inviabilizava, quem viabiliza a
sociabilidade, ela consegue a remissão,
a timidez acerbada, soma e a
socialização torna-se
viável. Timidez acerbada some. Deve ser
some, né? Não soma, né? Você acha que se
existisse mais pesquisas científicas
poderíamos encontrar a cura do
autismo? Olha, eu acho difícil, viu? Só
que tá aqui uns 100 anos, viu? É muito
complexa a
doença. Tanto o autismo com esquizofreni
são muito complexos.
Eh, ela é multifatorial, tem muita coisa
envolvida, tem muito fator de risco que
tá aumentando para que aumente essas
doenças aí. Então, eu acho muito difícil
ter uma solução em poucas décadas para
essas
doenças. Então, a gente não pode falar
de cura de autismo, nem de
esquizofrênia. a gente pode falar de
reversão e também eh estratégias
personalizadas como treinamento de
habilidades sociais,
modelagem, terapia
comportamental, terapia aba, por
exemplo, né?
Então, a gente tem que pegar esse
pessoal e auxiliar eles no
desenvolvimento de competências sociais
de forma gradual e
respeitosa. Então você você melhorar uma
sociabilidade de um autista, como é o
caso do meu filho, não significa
necessariamente você vai curar, mas você
vai reverter parcialmente ou totalmente
o impacto pior do problema, tá?
Então, por tudo que eu vejo aí e pela
complexidade da doença, a gente vai ter
muitos desafios aí pelo futuro e eu não
acredito que menos 100 anos isso aí vai
ser resolvido, se é que a humanidade vai
durar esse esse tanto aí,
né? O problema é que são muitas doenças
em uma, né? Na verdade, que a gente
chama de autismo é um termo guarda-chuva
para um monte de doença diferente que
tem manifestação parecida. Esse é meu
entendimento sobre o
problema. A esquizofrenia, a situação é
muito parecida. você vai conseguir
reverter parcialmente os problemas, mas
não vai conseguir de fato curar a pessoa
do ponto de
vista estrito, né, da dessa palavra aí.
Ah, há alguns meses fiz uma pergunta
sobre trocosoplasmosas que foi citado
por Olá de Carvalho sobre a possível
causa da burrice
brasileira. É isso é uma afirmação assim
muito pouco sólida, né?
É difícil você chegar nessa conclusão e
baseado em que que ele chegou nisso? Tem
muitos casos, desculpa, de
toxoplasmose que são pouco sintomáticos
ou assintomáticas,
né? Poderia ser sim uma causa de défic
intelectual, né? Uma
toxoplasmose congênita, porém é muito
complicada. Eu não sei de onde ele tirou
esses dados aí, entendeu?
De novo, eu não sou um seguidor do Olavo
de Carvalho. Eu conheço alguma coisa
sobre ele. Na verdade, eu escuto,
escutava mais antigamente, hoje não tô
escutando tanto, eh, material de pessoal
que era ex-estudante do Olaf de
Carvalho, mas eu não sou assim um
estudante nem seguidor do Olaf de
Carvalho, tá?
Então essa afirmação aí eu
acho bastante complicada porque eu nunca
vi nenhum material falando sobre isso de
que tocão plasmas poderia ser a causa da
deficiência intelectual de alguns
brasileiros ou ou da maioria dos
brasileiros.
Existem artigos científicos que
corroboram o fato de o povo brasileiro
ser um dos mais burros do mundo, como os
exames internacionais supostamente
falam. Bem, vamos lá. Tem resultados aí
do PISA, né, que é o esse exame
internacional de inteligência, né?
No caso, esse estudo PISA de 2022
mostrou que o Brasil tem um desempenho
abaixo da média, né, da
OCDE em matemática, leitura e ciências,
mas isso é muito mais por deficiência da
educação brasileira, tá?
O problema aí não é tanto questões aí de
doença ou de um déficit
intelectual por si genético, nada disso.
É problema de educação no Brasil que é
muito
fraco. tem um artigo,
né, que diz o
seguinte, que alunos de institutos
federais que t educação melhor tem um
desempenho similar a países
desenvolvidos, tá? Então, o problema é a
rede de ensino, não é outros fatores,
não. Outra coisa que a gente tem que
lembrar que esses testes padronizados
eles avaliam competências específicas
ligadas à educação e não a inteligência
inata das pessoas. Vocês devem conhecer
vários casos aí de pessoas que não
tiveram educação formal, que foram muito
bem na vida, né? tinham aí muitas
características de inteligência social,
emocional e que foram muito bem na
vida. Então, esses estudos aí, eles
criticam principalmente o sistema
educacional brasileiro, não
necessariamente a capacidade intelectual
dos
brasileiros. OK?
Então, a gente não tem ainda, a gente
carece de
estudos que possam avaliar a
inteligência inata da população.
Esses testes eles avaliam competências
específicas, OK? Espero que tenha ficado
claro
isso. Vamos lá, próxima pergunta.
Doutor, de acordo com essa tabela de
óleos
vegetais ou o artigo do Mercola, o ácido
linoleico, a principal responsável pelos
efeitos nocivos de óleos vegetais. Sim,
essa informação vem muito do bercola
mesmo. Esse efeito ocorre com o uso do
óleo em Natura, por exemplo, quando
usado para fazer a maionese ou apenas
quando o óleo é aquecido. Não, o
problema é que esses óleos eles já são
naturalmente aquecidos e e acrescidos aí
de toxinas quando eles são
processados na fábrica, tá? Então o
problema ele é antes de você comprar o
óleo. Não adianta até você consumir o
óleo de soja sem aquecer, porque ele já
foi aquecido antes e já foi submetido a
processos industriais nocivos,
tá? É lógico, quanto mais você queimar
esse óleo, pior a situação, tá? Mas não
quer dizer se você consumir ele em
natura sem aquecer, não vai ter problema
não, tá?
Bem, mas se você fritar o óleo de soja
vai piorar a situação, porque no
cozimento prolongado vai ser formado
substâncias como hidróxido, peróxidos e
aldeídos que danificam as membranas
celulares do DNA.
Tem estudos que mostram que as
partículas de LDL do organismo, contendo
ácido linoleico
oxidado, são mais propensas a se
acumular nas artérias e desencadeiam
placas
ateroscleróticas,
certo? Então eu recomendo não consumir o
óleo de soja mesmo em Natura, se você
puder evitar, tá?
E tem problema também do excesso de
ômega-6 que tem nesses óleos aí, né, que
no caso linoleico é um desses ômega-6
aí. E a o desequilíbrio entre ômega-3 e
ômega6 também aumenta a inflamação
crônica. Alimentos cultivados de forma
hidropônica, qual sua opinião?
Bem, eu particularmente eu não gosto
muito do aspecto das dos vegetais
hidropônicos, né? Eles têm a vantagem de
ter menos
exposição a
alguns algumas pragas, né, agrícolas. E
aí, por esse fato de não tá exposto às
pragas, vai ter menos necessidade de
você colocar os agrotóxicos, né? Então
isso tem uma grande vantagem
hidropônico, né? Mas eu lembro quando eu
comia
eh um agrião, que é um vegetal que eu
sempre gostei muito, o agrião
hidropônico, ele era horrível, né? ele
era
subdesenvolvido, ele não tinha nem um
pouco
da das características de um agrião
normal, assim, tá? Então assim, eu acho
que entre um
hidropônico e um vegetal com agrotóxico
é melhor hidropônico, mas eu preferiria
um orgânico não hidropônico, tá? Essa
que é a minha
opinião. Na live passada foi exposto que
a dieta cetogênica pode ser prejudicial
em alguns cânceres, mas é o jejum.
Por criar cetose também pode alimentar
câncer. Não entendi. Ou o jejum é neutro
e ajuda a evitar inibir qualquer câncer.
Não, o jejum vai prevenir o câncer, não
vai sozinho resolver o problema, né, no
sentido de prevenir todos os cânceres,
mas ele ajuda
muito. Na verdade, essa história da
cetose, vocês estão confundindo muito,
tá? É, a cetose leve é muito boa pra
saúde, tá? Não vai acontecer da pessoa
ter câncer com cetose leve só porque tem
alguns cânceres que se alimentam de
gordura, tá? Vocês estão confundindo os
dois
conceitos, tá? Uma coisa é você falar
que a diacetogênica previne câncer e
isso é verdade. Outra coisa você falar
que todos os cânceres do mundo só
alimento de glicose, que a gente já sabe
que não é assim, tá?
Prevenção, sim, dieta cetogênica pode
ajudar muito, só que não quer dizer que
todas as pessoas que já t o câncer
instalado vão conseguir resolver o
problema com a dieta cetogênica, porque
tem alguns câncer que se alimentam de
gordura, tá? Eu acho que esse que é o
conceito aqui
essencial que não tá sendo entendido,
tá?
E o jejum tem algumas vantagens em
relação à dieta cetogênica, né? Porque o
jejum não apenas
induzetose, mas também reduz fatores
pró-inflamatórios, como é o caso da
insulina do IGF1, que eu comentei mais
cedo nessa live.
Existe também um papel aí do jejum
intermitente na estimulação da
autofagia, né, que é uma limpeza das
células danificadas, que isso vai
prevenir o câncer também, que tá
dissociado isso do da questão
cetogênica. E é comprovado também que o
jejum intermitente aumenta a
sensibilidade de células cancerígenas ao
tratamentos com quimioterapia.
O jejum pode proteger células saudáveis
dos efeitos colaterais da quimioterapia.
OK?
Tem outras coisas também que eu queria
acrescentar aqui, tá? Tem estudos
recentes do memórium slow caterine que
mostrou que o jejum pode melhorar a
função das células natural killer, que
são células de defesa imunológica, que
podem eliminar as células cancerígenas.
Então o jejum intermitente é mais
importante do que a dieta cetogênica,
mas ambos
são podem causar prevenção aí do câncer,
tá? E a dieta cetogênica também ela não
pode ter excesso de caloria, tá? Se ela
for excessivamente alta a caloria dela
em gordura, em alguns casos ela pode ser
procial, tá?
Foi falado na live passada que o carne
de porco inspira cuidados no quesito
alimentação do animal antes do abate
para consumo humano. Isso eu falei isso
mesmo. Que pode causar problemas de
saúde graves ao ser humano, dependendo
da abordagem. Mas e a gordura do porco?
Ela é frita e aquecida a temperaturas
muito altas.
Essa temperatura não mataria qualquer
contaminação que a carne. Então é porque
o cisterco ele fica na carne, fica no
músculo, ele não fica na gordura, tá?
Eh, não acho que isso seja um problema,
não. Você pode ficar tranquilo de
usar, né, a banha de porco para fritura,
tá? Porque o problema do c seco tá na no
músculo, não tá na gordura.
E realmente a temperatura alta poderia
tá resolvendo esses
problemas, tá? Aí eu tô falando de
parasita, né? Porque a gordura pode ter
bactéria também,
né? Então a vigilância sanitária
continua sendo importante, mas sim, se
você pegar essa banha e aquecer ela na
panela, você vai est eliminando
praticamente todos os problemas.
Mas a gente tem que lembrar também que
tem toxinas, né, e contaminantes
químicos que não vai não vão ser
eliminados com o aumento da temperatura.
lembrar sobre metais pesados de oxinas,
né, e outras toxinas que podem se
acumular na gordura do
porco. Então, sempre tome cuidado.
Priorize o consumo de bande pouco
certificada, de animais criados, soltos,
se for
possível.
Você pode associar também na culinária
banha com ervas antimicrobianas e
antioxidantes que podem auxiliar na
neutralização dos radicais e livres.
OK.
Estava com aia por alguns dias, tenho
deato e vi uma receita de suco de batata
doce crua. Me ajudou bastante, já que
mesmo com dieta tem períodos que ainda
sinto um pouco de
aia. Porém, assisti um outro vídeo
falando que a batata doce tem muito
potássio e pode prejudicar os
rins. Qual a sua opinião? Ah, por que
que eu acho que
seria isso seria uma coisa coerente?
Não, tá. Tenho batido meia batata doce
em suco de abacaxi e limão por dia por
duas semanas. Veja bem, você já você
come já batata doce no dia a dia. Alguém
fica preocupado comidade de potássio que
tem ali,
né? Eu acho só seria um problema em quem
tem insuficiência renal já. Aí o
potássio poderia prejudicar essa
pessoa. E eu continuia fazendo isso. Não
acho que isso é um problema relevante,
não. Bem, eu dei uma levantada aqui
sobre o assunto. Uma batata média doce
tem 150 g e 350 mg de potássio, que é um
valor bem abaixo da recomendação diária
da Organização Mundial de
Saúde. Para uma pessoa normal que não
tem problema de desfícia renal, o
consumo moderado não vai oferecer
riscos,
certo? Eu só não faria isso se tivesse
histórico de doença renal, tá?
ou ainda os medicamentos que poderiam
afetar os níveis de potássio acumulando
ele no
organismo. Então não vejo problema de
você continuar utilizando, tá?
Idoso que retirou a próstata por estar
aumentada. Precisa continuar com
suplemento salmeto. Teria algo a mais
que seria importante? Bom, geralmente se
tirou, vai ter que ver o seguinte,
geralmente a cirurgia para doença
benigna não tira a próstata inteira.
Se foi o
caso, pode ser necessário continuar
assim o São Palmeto, se a pessoa não
tirou totalmente a próstata, que é o
caso quando é doença benigna, só se tira
a próstata inteira em doença maligna,
né, com câncer de próstata.
Então, se você tiver certeza que foi
retirada toda totalmente a próstata, aí
sim você poderia estar suspendendo o
salmeto. Mas se for uma cirurgia que
tirou só o miolo da prósta, como é o
caso
de prósta benigna, aí eu recomendaria
utilizar sim, talvez não de forma
imediata, mas depois de alguns anos da
cirurgia, tá?
Mulher de mais de 50 anos com diabetes,
não faz tratamento, come de tudo. já
tomou berberina em 500 mg, mas não é
constante. O índice de açúcar no sangue
já chegou a mais de 200 no último exame
de
sangue. Recomenda a beberina de quanto
para ela? Ó, a beberina a gente usa de
entre 500 mg por dia até 1500 mg por
dia, tá? Então de 500 mg até 500 mg três
vezes ao dia. Tá bom? Esse que é o minha
recomendação. Mas tem que fazer a dieta
sim, tá?
Importante que a bemina não vai
substituir a necessidade de medicamentos
em vários casos, tá? Tem que ficar
analisar isso daí.
Doutor, para uma testosterona inferior a
220 e a testosterona livre inferior a
40, ou seja, ambas em valores baixos
para um homem de 45 anos seria indicado
TRT ou estimular o eixo? Eu sempre opto
primeiro estimular o eixo com
colomifeno, tá? Geralmente resolve
especialmente a nessa idade, mas tem que
tá vendo como é que está o LH, que
geralmente funciona bem quando LH está
abaixo de cinco.
Ã, para que a média longo prazo não haja
prejuízos como perda de massa magra,
diminuição de massa óssea, entre outros.
Sim. Aí primeiro tenta o clomifeno, só
não tentaria o clomifeno de
primeira se o
LH. Aí nesse caso a gente entra direto
com a testosterona, tá? Mas geralmente é
muito difícil o cromifeno não funcionar,
tá? Na minha experiência ele funciona
bem para homens mais jovens assim, tá? É
justamente para não ter esse prejuízo
que você comentou na pergunta
aqui. Doutor, se eu tenho experiência
com uso de mesterolona proviron para
reduzir o SHBG elevado, não recomendo,
tá? Isso aí é um
anabolizante, ele é geralmente utilizado
eh quando as pessoas que fazem
fisiculturismo e fazem ciclo hormonal,
depois eles usam
proviron. Eh, esse é um dos recursos que
se usa vior oral.
para poder recuperar o eixo, tá? Isso aí
é uma prática de fisiculturista junto
com o uso de clomifeno e
tamoxifeno e também muitas vezes
de
hã
HCG.
Então, se for para recuperar aí de ciclo
de primeiro que eu não recomendo que
faça ciclo, né, para anabolismo, né?
Se fizer, você pode até utilizar, porque
ele é uma um anabolizante fraco que ele
é utilizado mais para ajudar a recuperar
o eixo depois que a pessoa faz um ciclo
intenso, tá? Mas eh na verdade o SHBG
ele não deve ser muito combatido de
forma direta, não, porque o SHBG elevado
muitas vezes ele tá sendo secundário,
outro problema e esse outro problema que
tem que ser atacado no SHBG de forma
direta, tá? Todos os anabolizantes
reduzem o SHBG, mas é uma redução
forçada. Так.
Tem pessoas que utilizam na prática
clínica o uso da
mesterolona para bloquear o SHBG para
ajudar a aumentar aí a testosterona
livre, mas sinceramente eu não acho isso
uma estratégia muito boa, não.
Existe tratamentos que associam uma
esterolona com clomifeno para aumentar a
contagem espermática.
Então eu não eu não sei por que que qual
que é a o objetivo da sua pergunta em
relação a SHBG. Existe estudos fazendo
associação de clomifena e mesterolona
paraa
infetilidade, mas eu não utilizaria isso
se o objetivo fosse só para baixar o SH
HBG, tá?
Doutor, uma testosterona total e livre
baixa após 45 anos pode estar associada
de alguma forma uma a maior
probabilidade de incidência de problemas
na próstata, como HPB, deve ser HPB, se
quis dizer, né? ou mesmo desenvolvimento
de câncer de próstata já com fator
hereditário
presente. Então, existe sim uma
evidência de que testosterona abaixo por
muitos anos aumenta o risco de câncer de
próstata, tá? Existe sim essa essa
informação, tá?
Tem uma interessa. interessante que tem
estudos que dizem que a terapia de
reposição hormonal em homens com
deficiência
androgênica
configurada tem efeitos paradoxais no
sentido de que alguns estudos apontam
aumento moderado do volume prostático e
outros não demonstram pior a
significativa dos
sintomas.
Espero ter respondido a sua pergunta.
Você tá ao vivo,
Fernando? Tá, tá sim. Deve ser o
Casteliano que fez a
pergunta. Próxima pergunta. Maria
Helena, quando faz colonoscopia, como
recuperar o intestino de forma mais
rápido? Bem, no caso, o que que eu
recomendo, né? O próprio preparo
intestinal da colonoscopia, ela de certa
maneira faz uma limpeza no intestino,
certo? Só que ela acaba também
diminuindo a diversidade bacteriana.
Então, o que eu recomendo para recuperar
o intestino de maneira mais rápida é o
consumo de prebiótico. São fibras bem
variadas, né? Então, consumir vegetais
coloridos, laranja, vermelho,
verde, roxo. Isso, os esses prebióticos,
né, esses polifenóis vão ajudar a
recuperar a flora. E também pode ser
utilizado probióticos juntos para
melhorar esse intestino. Quando sente
muito desconforto intestinal, se aperta
a barriga dói com feijão, até dor de
cabeça, tem outro grão menos agressivo.
Uma coisa pode fazer é deixar de molho
esse feijão por 24 horas antes de
consumir. Isso reduz os fitatos, reduz
aí as substâncias que tem no feijão que
causam os gases, tá? Mas sim, eh, grão
de bico tem menos problema. Lentilha dá
menos problema, tá? Os outras
oleaginosas t
menos dessas todas. Acho que a lentilha
é a
melhor em termos de evitar os gases,
tá? Bem, acho que temos algumas
perguntas ao vivo aqui também. Vamos ver
aqui. Par.
H, no caso, para evitar parasitas,
principalmente quando consumido comida
japonesa, peixe cru, ideal seria
consumir Coca-Cola, PH ácido ou suco de
abacaxi
junto. É, o Coca-Cola não é saudável,
mas nesse caso específico acho que pode
ajudar sim, tá?
Suco de abacaxi. Acho que não. Eu acho
que eu não teria acidez suficiente
para reduzir esse problema.
Não. Liberaram aqui no Canadá. Thiago
mora no Canadá, ó. Tá falando da
maconha. E o centro da cidade está tudo
cheio de zumbi por causa de drogas
pesadas. Tá vendo aí que eu tava
falando, né? O Thiago tá confirmando a
impressão que eu tenho sobre esse
assunto aí.
Sim, com certeza,
Denise, com
certeza. Boa noite,
George. Vou colocar os dados do
Alexandre Costa no grupo, tá? Eh, tá
complicado aqui no chat. Por quê? Não
entendi. Em relação ao Proviron, seria
para reduzir esse HBG em virtude do
aumento causado pelo clomifeno? Ah, sim.
É porque realmente o cromifeno ele
aumenta o
estradiol também junto com a
testosterona e pode aumentar o SHBG.
Sim, mas eu não acho uma boa ideia
bloquear o SHBG não, viu? Ô Fernando,
dessa maneira não. É uma estratégia que
muita gente usa, mas eu acho que deve
ser evitado,
tá? Sim, sim. Seu argumento faz todo
sentido, Fernanda.
É, só que o Proviron é uma é um
andrógeno,
né, que não é natural, né, é um
anabolizante que pode também dar uma
sobrecarga no fígado, tá? Eu eu evitaria
o uso do proviron,
OK? Eu evitaria eu poderia utilizar um
fitoterápico aí, no caso de oica dá uma
reduzida leve no SHVG. poderia ser uma
uma
solução. De nada,
Antônio.
OK. Não fica like
direto,
tá? Eu acho que eu já vi todas as
perguntas, né, de hoje, né, gente? Já
deu mais de uma hora de
live. Eu tô um pouco cansado, acho que
eu vou encerrar aqui, tá?
Então, deixa eu mudar aqui a visão.
Agradeço imensamente aí a vocês que
participaram da live ao vivo. Deixa eu
ver aqui no
grupo se colocou aqui. Aqui nova ordem
mundial, indústria
farmacêutica. Ah, você colocou também
aqui o Telegram dele aqui, né?
canal do escritor Alexandre
Costa. Ah, você colocou o Instagram
também. Obrigado pelas informações, viu,
Antônio. Eu vou depois eh ver isso daí.
Obrigado a todos vocês que participaram
ao vivo. Um grande abraço, um beijo no
coração e até semana que vem. Ciao.
Ciao.